c'est une défaite qui fait mal parce
qu'on avait on avait l'ambition le rêve
aussi de gagner le premierers match dans
cette compétition mais voilà ça c'est
fait c'est just c'est just un match il
reste encore de matchs à jouer bah je
trouve qu'on a fait une belle prestation
ce soir face à une belle équipe de la
Côte d'Ivoire maintenant le résultat
c'est pas ce qu'on espérait mais on va
continuer de travailler pour faire mieux
le prochain match contre la Guinée
équatoriale parce que là maintenant il
nous faut des points et puis donc le
prochain match sera décisif déjà pour
nous après malheureusement c'est qu'on
prend ce but très tôt donc forcément ça
change les plans mais malgré ce premier
but j'estime qu'on a essayé de jouer
qu'on a produit du football on a même
fait Jer égal par moment avec la Côte
d'Ivoire après aujourd'hui il nous a
manqué l'efficacité soit défensivement
et offensivement je pense qu'on aurait
pu au moins espérer marquer un but déjà
ce soir oui un match un peu frustrant
après on a perdu contre une grosse
équipe on doit dire contre pour moi un
des favoris à à porter cette canne qui
joue à domicile après match frustré
parce que quand même j'ai l'impression
que on méritait un meilleur score quand
même on a eu des belles occasions de
mettre un ou deux buts après on les a
pas mis mais j'espère que notre chance
tournera dans 5
jours